en medio de una guerra por el poder en
Sudán los civiles se organizan para
coordinar la asistencia médica y la
evacuación en medio de los intensos
combates en la capital jartum el
ejército y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas
de apoyo rápido se disputan el control
Cuando comenzó la crisis y la guerra en
Sudán la gente se sorprendió y no sabían
qué hacer entonces comenzaron a
compartir lo que necesitaban en redes
sociales y quienes tenían suministros
disponibles los compartían tenía un
sitio web personal y lo convertí en una
plataforma dedicada a publicar pedidos
de ayuda y anuncios de suministros
Adele es desarrollador web y hace parte
de un comité de resistencia como son
conocidos en Sudán estas redes de ayuda
humanitaria los comités han encabezado
un movimiento social y político a favor
de la democracia en Sudán desde 2019 y
han enfrentado la represión del actual
régimen militar instaurado tras el golpe
de estado en 2021
los métodos informales que servían para
organizar manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de facto Ahora son utilizados
para coordinar ayuda humanitaria en las
redes sociales hashtags como not to
world se han viralizado y habitantes de
barrios asolados por la violencia en
jartum integraron grupos de WhatsApp
la gente comienza a unirse llegamos a
1200 personas y todo se comunican bien
en cada uno de los grupos de área cada
vez que revisó un área determinada me
doy cuenta que las personas realmente se
están comunicando y logramos obtener
medicamentos alimentos para algunos todo
va bien el propósito de Esto va bien
quienes quieren huir de la violencia
dependen de los comités para obtener
combustible pero su trabajo depende de
un hilo debido a la falta de apoyo
económico de organizaciones
internacionales y a la afectación en el
servicio de internet